How do you articulate your thoughts
clearly without overthinking every
single word? You know that moment when
you're talking halfway through your
sentence and you don't even know what
point you're trying to make. Hi, my
name's Vin. I've coached millions of
people to improve their communication
and the three frameworks I'm going to
share with you in this video will help
you sound well-spoken and more
articulate in professional and personal
conversations. And I'll break it into
the three most common scenarios that
play out for most people. The first is
when you do know your stuff, but you
can't explain it simply. The second is
when you don't know much about what's
being discussed, but you don't want to
come across completely clueless. And the
third, which is the most common
scenario, especially at work, is when
you actually do know the answer, but the
pressure of being in front of your peers
and your leaders causes your brain to
scramble and then you go blank. I used
to think, "Oh, articulation? That's a
speaking problem." Well, it's not. Messy
words come from messy thinking. So, the
real skill isn't just learning how to
talk better, it's learning how to think
more clearly. And when you're put on the
spot, frameworks will help you think
more clearly so that you can sound more
well-spoken and articulate. So, let's
start with scenario one, which is when
you're actually knowledgeable on the
topic, but you can't articulate well.
When I run my communication classes and
workshops, a large portion of my
students fall into this specific
category. They're engineers, doctors,
and lawyers. They're highly
knowledgeable individuals, but when I
ask them the reason why they joined my
class, the number one reason I hear is,
"Vin, I struggle to explain my ideas
clearly." You've probably been in this
scenario as well. You're trying to
explain the topic you know well, but you
overcomplicate it. You go in circles and
you can slowly start to see the other
person look more and more confused. And
the worst part is, you leave the
conversation thinking, "Maybe maybe I
don't understand my topic as well as I
thought I did." But here's what's
actually going on. You know your topic
well because you've studied it a lot,
but you can't explain it to someone
well, because you haven't explained it a
lot. That's all that it is. Learning and
explaining are two completely separate
skills. You've done thousands of hours
of one and almost none of the other.
That's why the world is full of
wonderful experts who actually can't
teach. They struggle to pass on their
knowledge to others without boring them
or losing them. So, before I share with
you the framework, the key point I want
you to take away here is that the best
teachers, the best explainers, they have
mastered the art of distillation.
They're able to distill the complex and
make it simple for you to understand. In
other words, they've learned to take
their messy thoughts and deliver it in a
clear and concise and coherent way. So,
when I want to learn how to explain
anything better, here's the framework
that I use. It's a simple four-step
loop. The first part of it is capture.
After that, you've got structure.
Then after that, you've got practice.
And then finally,
you've got iterate. And then it's back
to capture all over again, therefore
being a loop. Let's start with capture,
number one. Which is what? It's writing.
And I know the second I say writing,
half of you are checking out now, but
stick with me here, because this is what
helps you think about something more
clearly. When a thought is in your head,
it's floating around, it's jumbled, it's
disjointed, and it's all over the place.
And it's almost impossible to shape
something you can't see. But the moment
you write it on paper or you type it
into a document, you're forced to turn
the feelings into words. And now the
thought is sitting there right in front
of you, where you can actually look at
it. The art of writing is the art of
making your thoughts visible. And to
give you a real example, every single
week I share a newsletter to my email
subscribers called The Weekly V. We've
actually got 2 million readers, and we
get a 50% open rate week to week and
that's just crazy. But the reason this
happens and the reason why I do it is
because it forces me to capture my
thoughts and then write about my
experiences in a way that becomes
helpful to our readers. So here are the
two steps to get your thoughts into
writing. The first one is just ask
yourself, what's the one thing I want to
get better at explaining? And then once
you've got that topic, the second thing
is, well, write down how you currently
explain it. Write it out exactly as you
would explain it. And at first, your
writing and explaining might not be in
the optimal order, but that's what the
next step is for, structure. Because
once you get all of your thoughts about
a specific topic down on paper, you can
now see the pieces and go, "Ah, I
shouldn't say that first. I should have
said this first. Actually, they need to
understand this before any of that's
going to make sense." You can only put
the puzzle together once you can see the
puzzle pieces. So now that you've
written out how you currently explain
the specific topic, look at the puzzle
pieces. Does it make sense? Is it too
long? Is it easy to understand? Is it
too much jargon? Is there an analogy, a
metaphor, or a simile that you can use
to simplify it? Give yourself permission
here to play. Add some new pieces.
Reorder the pieces. So it'll be engaging
enough and simple enough that even a
teenager could understand. Then the next
step is what separates great thinkers
from great speakers. Because without
practice, without you saying it out
loud, all of your brilliance, your
knowledge, your ideas, it just stays on
the page. So here's what I want you to
do. Turn on your camera. Could be your
phone. Just hit record and start talking
through the idea with the new structure
that you've written down. And as you
practice this out loud, you'll get a
sense of what it feels like in your
mouth, quite literally. And as you do
that, you'll be able to identify where
things flow, where they don't. When I'm
scripting and writing these YouTube
videos, for example, the moment I sit
down and practice saying it out loud, I
can immediately pick up the parts that
don't logically flow well. And the more
you do this, the better you'll get at
simplification, because that's what
great communicators do. And the final
step here is iterate.
And what I mean by this is you now have
to listen back to the video you just
recorded and ask yourself, was it clear?
Was it concise? Was it coherent?
Identify where the explanation gets too
complex or messy. And then you go back
to capture and you start the whole loop
again. This might mean making it
shorter, changing some of the pieces,
restructuring again, and sometimes it
means throwing out the whole damn thing
and chucking it in the bin, starting
from scratch. This is the work required
if you want to be an influential
communicator. This is the practice
required. That's how you stop being the
expert that nobody understands and you
start becoming the expert that everybody
understands. And by the way, if you want
to learn more frameworks to improve your
ability to articulate well, especially
when you're put on the spot, make sure
you click the link in the description or
you can scan the QR code that's on
screen for my free 2-hour training,
where I'm going to teach you three
powerful communication frameworks to
filter your thinking through so that it
helps you come across more well-spoken.
So, check it out. It's completely free.
Now, the next scenario is the complete
opposite. This is where you're in a
conversation and then the topic changes
to one you don't know much about. What
should you do in this scenario? Should
you pretend you know and then fake it?
Or should you just say, "I don't know."?
These are two great questions. Let me
tell you what I do. Number one, I name
what I know.
Number two, I name what I'm still
working out. And then, number three, I
ask a question that moves the
conversation forward. Let me show you
what that sounds like.
>> So, what do you think about all this AI
stuff? Do you think it's going to take
over everyone's jobs? What I know is
that AI has gotten scary good at the
narrow and repetitive stuff, the tasks
that follow really clear rules. And the
part that I'm I'm still trying to work
out myself is where's the limit? Because
every time I try to get it to do
something difficult, it often fails. And
can I ask what's your take? Do you see
it as a tool that replaces just tasks or
do you think it's gradually going to
replace people in their roles? Maybe
it's going to replace your role, Peter.
No, [laughter] no, no, don't get me
wrong. I'm not going to fire Peter and
replace him with AI. Why? Well, because
can AI warm my seat for me every morning
before I get in? Can AI make me my
coffee exactly how I want it at 8:00
a.m. on the dot when I arrive in the
office and place it in my hand the
moment I snap my fingers? Didn't snap my
fingers, Pete. Mate, that was premature.
Did you catch what happened in the skit
though? Even though someone asked me to
speak on a topic that I didn't know much
about, I was still able to come across
articulate, thoughtful, and competent by
following the framework I shared right
here. Now, here's an unexpected thing
you can do that will increase your
relatability, likability, and even
respect. This is for when you get asked
a question and you don't know the
answer. In these moments, contrary to
popular belief, it's actually okay to
say I don't know. One caveat here
though, you must have previous to this
question already have demonstrated value
and credibility. If these things have
already been established and you say the
words I don't know, it humanizes you.
I've done this before in my workshops. I
don't know the answer to that.
And I believe it's very important for me
to clearly state that when I don't know
it. So, I I don't I'm not qualified to
answer that.
>> That's actually That's a good answer.
>> Oh, okay.
I thought it was so yeah.
I used to believe that saying I don't
know would make people respect me less.
But like you saw in the video, because
I've already added value that morning,
when I said the words I don't know in a
situation where I actually didn't know,
people respected me more. And there's
another benefit. It takes an enormous
amount of pressure off you when you know
you can say I don't know. Because most
people walk into a client meeting, a
presentation, or a conversation with
their boss believing they need to have
an answer for everything. But when you
give yourself permission to say I don't
know, you're no longer trying to be
ChatGPT. You can slow down, acknowledge
what you do know, and because of this
framework here, you can now explain it
clearly, which increases credibility. So
that when there's something you don't
know, saying I don't know doesn't ruin
your reputation. In actual reality, it
increases the trust and respect that
people have for you. Because they know
when you don't know, you're not going to
outright lie to them. And now for the
final scenario, one where we are all too
familiar with. This is when you know
your stuff, but when someone asks you a
question, the pressure of being in the
spotlight and needing to answer in the
moment causes you to go completely
blank. And this has happened to me more
than most people on the biggest stages
around the world, so I feel qualified to
give you some real advice here. It's
like when you accidentally open all the
browser tabs in one click causing your
browser to lag. Same thing with your
brain. When someone asks you a question
and all of your thoughts fire at once,
damn it, Peter. That wasn't a coffee
click. You've got to hear the
difference. Learn to hear the
difference.
That's a coffee click. That's a click
for emphasis. Come on, mate. Get it
together.
Now, as I was saying, all your thoughts
just fire at once, and then as a result,
your brain can't decide which one to
grab and where to start. And from the
outside, it makes you look incompetent
if you freeze for too long. So then as a
result, you feel the pressure to speak,
and then you start speaking your
thoughts out loud causing you to go in
circles and ramble. This is the
framework you need to remember in those
moments, and it's called POP. P O P. And
the first one stands for pause. I know
how counterintuitive this feels because
again, you feel like you should respond
immediately.
Wrong click, Peter. But you feel like
you should respond immediately to show
how knowledgeable you are. But that
doesn't work. What you need is to take a
couple of seconds to think about your
response before giving it. And you'll be
surprised how giving yourself an extra
moment or two to think actually helps
you get more clarity on your thoughts.
And you might think this is weird, but
trust me, it's only weird if you make it
weird. Watch this example of me at one
of my workshops where someone's asking
me a question. I want you to count how
many seconds I paused for while I was
thinking.
>> Are there any stories you have yet to
share
with us?
>> Mhm.
>> That you would really like to share that
would
kind of nurture a part of your heart.
>> Gosh.
Now, did I come across awkward? Did I
come across like I was panicking and
freaking out and freezing? Or did I come
across as if I was someone who was
putting a lot of thought into their
response?
That's the power of the pause when you
do it confidently. And you know what?
Even though I took that long to pause,
guess what happened after that? Have a
look at this.
Would you all mind having a chat amongst
yourselves for just a couple of minutes
while I really sit and think with this?
Is that okay?
Okay, I'll just I'll just sit and have a
think.
>> [laughter]
>> Yes, that's right. I asked for more time
because I have confidence that if you
give me an extra 2 minutes, I'm going to
be able to give you an incredible amount
of value in my response. Now, the next
part of the framework is O. And what
does O stand for? Stands for one
thought.
Begin your response with the sentence,
"The one thought that comes to mind is"
What this does for you is that it forces
your brain to focus just on one point to
share instead of trying to share every
single point that comes to mind. And by
doing this, it allows you to respond
faster because of the focus, and not get
stuck in analysis paralysis. This is
what causes people to freeze and worse,
ramble. Oh, it's the worst. And what
this does for the listener is it tells
them you've actually got a lot of
thoughts on this, but you're
deliberately selecting one to share. And
the final P is proof.
Once you've shared your thought, you now
back up that thought with an example. It
could be a story, a result, an
observation, a statistic. This helps
solidify and add more credibility to the
thought that you just shared.
Now, let me give you an example.
>> Vin, I'm curious. What are some clever
ways for us to get our YouTube
subscribers to hit subscribe?
>> Mhm.
>> Any ideas?
>> You know what?
The one thought that comes to mind is
that we can create a skit where we
passively speak to the audience about
the importance of why they should
subscribe. Let me give you an example.
Because when we do it directly to the
camera, people tend to resist because
they don't want to be told what to do.
That's why we should indirectly, through
a skit, speak to the subconscious to get
them to subscribe. I mean, it's subtle,
it's clever, it's completely invisible.
They're not going to notice it.
>> Yeah, you mean you mean just like this,
right?
>> No, you idiot. That's way too obvious.
You know what to do. You see, pop
Pop is one of the many frameworks that
exist to help you articulate your
thoughts more clearly. So, if you want
to learn more of my favorite
communication frameworks, make sure you
check out the free training I mentioned
earlier in the video. It's in the
description and the QR code is here.
It's going to help you create more
structure and clarity every time you
speak. So, here's my challenge to you
this week. Pick a topic you know a lot
about and take it through the first
framework. Capture it, write it down,
everything that comes to mind. Then,
when your thoughts are visible,
restructure it, remix it, add stuff, mix
it all around. Most people stop there,
but without the next step of practice
and reading your thoughts out loud,
you'll never be able to explain anything
simply and articulately. And finally,
iterate. That's how you start practicing
the habit of thinking and speaking
clearly. You can't do one without the
other. And I want to leave you with this
message. If you can't communicate
clearly right now, and if you don't see
yourself as a great communicator right
now, I want you to remember how you
currently communicate is just a series
of behaviors that you can improve over
time by practicing the things you
learned in this video. You're not stuck
with the way you communicate. So, don't
be so attached to who you are in the
present that you don't give the future
version of you a chance. I'll see you in
the next video.